Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here.
As you might have been hoping, Captain America
Civil War has 2 post-credit scenes.
One which appears just after the credits for
the main cast and crew, and another after
the full set of credits has finished rolling.
In this video I’m going to talk about both
these scenes and just to be clear there are
spoilers ahead, so you want to avoid those
you can watch my spoiler-free review right
here.
The mid-credits start with Bucky being tended
to by a doctor in a super high-tech medical
facility and his metal arm is still missing
from when it was blasted off by Iron Man in
the movie.
We then see Steve Rogers there with Bucky
and he asks his friend, "You sure about this?"
to which Bucky replies "I can't trust my own
mind so until they figure out how to get this
stuff outta my head, I think going back under
is the best thing for everybody."
Bucky is then strapped into an upright cryo-chamber
and frozen, a nod to the flashback scene in
The Winter Soldier film where Zola orders
Bucky to be put on ice and also a call back
to how he was put into cryostasis by the Russians
in the Captain America comics while they figured
out what to do with him.
The camera then cuts to Black Panther and
Captain America.
Steve Rogers thanks T'Challa who responds
"Your friend and my father, they were both
victims.
If I can help one of them find peace."
The advanced medical centre reflects the fact
that in the Marvel comics, Wakanda is a wealthy
and technologically advanced nation thanks
to its vibranium deposits.
It looks like the Wakandan doctors and scientists
might work on how to erase the HYDRA programming
from Bucky's brain.
Rogers then warns that "if they find out he's
here, they'll come for him" to which Black
Panther responds "let them try".
The camera then pans away from the medical
centre to a view of a misty jungle location
with a waterfall and mountains in the background
and a huge black panther statue.
So this is a pretty cool tease for the 2018
Black Panther movie with an intriguing peek
at what Wakanda looks like in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe.
And with Marvel Studios president and producer
Kevin Feige saying that the Black Panther
movie has important links to Infinity War
Part 1, it looks likely we'll see Bucky brought
back for both those movies, and possibly we'll
also see some Avengers, or someone else coming
after Bucky in the Black Panther movie.
By the way, there's a really cool easter egg
to do with Bucky being shut down in the mid-credits
scene.
The working title of Civil War was "Sputnik",
and in the comics "Sputnik" is the safeword
that the Russians implanted in Bucky as a
safety mechanism to shut him down in case
he went crazy, a bit like how the other Winter
Soldiers in this movie turn against their
guards.
Moving on to the post-credits, this scene
starts with Peter Parker in his bedroom with
Aunt May calling and asking him who it was
who hit him.
Peter replies "some guy" while he's fiddling
with what looks like his web shooter around
his wrist.
It's a call back to the airport fight scene
and when Aunt May asks what the guy's name
is, Peter replies "Steve", in other words
Steve Rogers.
Aunt May asks if it's Steve from 12-C, the
guy with overbite, but Peter says that "he's
from Brooklyn" which is where Captain America
is from.
The mention of 12-C could be a little easter
egg to the price of the first Spider-Man comic
which cost 12 cents.
And the point about 'the overbite' is a funny
call-back to Tony Stark telling Cap in this
movie that "Sometimes I want to punch you
in your perfect teeth."
As Peter's talking to Aunt May, he activates
the shooter which sends a beam of light up
onto the ceiling, but he hides it away quickly
when Aunt May comes in the room.
May asks him more about the fight and Peter
mentions that Steve's friend is huge, a funny
reference to his fight with Giant-Man at the
airport.
Aunt May then leaves, and Peter uncovers his
arm with the camera panning up to reveal a
beam projecting a very cool Spidey symbol
on to the ceiling.
The film then ends with the words "Spider-Man
will return."
So this piece of tech is likely something
Tony Stark has made or enhanced for Peter
Parker, remember we already saw Tony create
an Iron Man glove out of a hi-tech device
on his wrist in this movie.
And Peter Parker's device is very much like
the Spider signal that Spider-Man has attached
to his belt in the comics.
By the way, given that Tony Stark's former
science bro Bruce Banner, aka the Hulk, is
currently AWOL, I really like the way Tony
and Peter seem to be on their way to becoming
the new science bros, with Tony likely having
provided Peter with his new Spidey suit for
the airport fight.
And with Robert Downey Jr now confirmed to
appear in Spider-Man Homecoming, it's a cool
hint that we can expect more tech geeking
out with Iron Man and Spider-Man in the 2017
solo movie.
OK guys, that's the mid-credits and post-credits
scenes from Captain America Civil War.
If you've seen the movie already, do you have
any cool theories about what they might mean
for future MCU movies?
By the way, coming up I've also got a cool
giveaway for this awesome hardback book "Captain
America: The Ultimate Guide to the First Avenger"
which is packed with tons of cool info and
images about Cap's 75-year history in Marvel
comics.
It'll be on my full easter egg guide for Civil
War, so make sure you're subbed to see that!
And if you wanna check out more of my videos
on Captain America Civil War, you can click
here for my full easter egg video guide to
the movie and here for my full Civil War playlist
with my review, cast interviews, and lots
more.
If you enjoyed this, don't forget to subscribe,
share and like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!